this is one of the first tour groups to
leave China moments after a ban on Group
Travel was partially lifted on Monday
the tourists flight left the southern
Chinese city of Guangzhou at 15 minutes
past midnight
I signed up as soon as I got the news of
overseas tourism I travel with my wife
and my daughter
last month the government allowed
Chinese travel agencies to provide
outbound group tours to 20 countries as
part of a pilot program
countries in Southeast Asia were some of
the most highly searched destinations by
Chinese Nationals
before the pandemic Thailand welcomed 11
million visitors from China it's
expecting 5 million this year
and expects them to spend nearly 30
billion dollars we are very happy and
I'm sure that the coming back of Chinese
would be booze up the Thai economy
significantly because as you know that
the revenue from the Thai tourism
industry is share about close to 20 of
the GDP so I think it's even proof that
the coming back of China or China is
back is the key of success of the Thai
tourism this year
in Bali Indonesia officials are hoping
two-thirds of the 1.2 million Chinese
visitors who came to the island before
the pandemic will return this year
the tourism Ministry is planning to
boost its marketing of Bali as a
paradise destination
and businesses are hoping for better
times ahead impact is very significant
because in our shop 80 of the customers
are Chinese so this is big for us
especially after we close down our shop
for about three years on Monday China
also allowed cross-border travel to
fully resume between the mainland and
the special administrative regions of
Hong Kong and Macau changes that many
hope will lead to the tourism industry
in the region thriving once again
Florence Louis Al Jazeera